the question I'm gonna leave is oh my
god that's so hard why are you so
terrible
oh my god nice date no no don't actually
absolutely understand leaving sexual
question how big is your time if you had
to sleep with anybody from our cast who
would it be
Oh God honestly you know the kind of
thing for Spanish men so I'd probably
have to save Angie because you know
she's Puerto Rican by penetration if you
could put a zipper on the mouth of one
of the girls for life who would it be
well silky because I know he's gonna be
very expressive with or without talking
so we're gonna hear what she has to say
whether that's it press on it off
[Music]
who's the trade of the season that is
dangerous
ha ha ha I'm sure that one came from a
kajada I'm gonna give it a tie and
definitely think I'm trade down and so
is my sister Kahana who probably asked
that question I'm really happy to be a
part of a season they have two black
Trey Queen honey hello if you had to
bang one of your season 11 sisters who
would it be and why I'm not listen I
don't do that whole Caspar fanny I did
that in the past I don't do that anymore
what would you have said differently in
your insurance intro oh that's so good
welcome to season 11 it looks like
things just got 11 June Gary off the top
of my head I think I would probably
change my whole look and I'd probably do
like a Mae West look like it's like a
whole a saloon western vibe and I'd be
like oh now you're gonna see how the
West is best I don't know I mean I don't
you want to rhyme something probably
really [ __ ] but denon and then if you
could change one thing about what you're
wearing today but would it be saying I
don't know this is a question I mean I
came up with this look for myself so
maybe
the color how about there okay we'll
just switch up the color who would you
kai Kai with this is a very sexual Bunch
half the questions have been teased you
know we've come through a situation
where you've been like held locked down
for so long and no being around other
than your sisters you know oh guy who
one night I'm skiing there's a lot of
people I guess I can't go with Brooklyn
but she's my mom I was it I got was
banjee hunter no Sochi he's my sister
it's just a big incest so marry kill I
love all the girls who would you pick I
think that's a good one well I would
marry Nina West cuz I know she had a
real job before those never had a 401k
I've heard about them and I want one
so Nina I would marry I would be B she
would get me stoned afterwards who would
I kill I I who asked who asked this
question
this is plastique so I go ahead and off
plastique what does the work room smell
like it literally felt like it was a
minute that it was called the whole
thing was called and I was like this is
suppose we Californian not 45 degrees
like Minnesota
so it just no like winter did you enjoy
working with Mercedes and I said I hated
everyone right I'm done
no actually Mercedes was one of my
favorite favorite Queens cuz she
reminded me a lot of my family was like
they're imparted like African lifestyles
being like well it takes a village to
raise a goat or like whatever the [ __ ]
saying is what is the grossest thing
you've ever done in drag I want to know
how gritty can you get what is the
nastiest thing you've done girl
I mean I've gave [ __ ] in drag before
not because I wanted to but the trade
wanted to and don't get it twisted don't
try to like you know get me to do it
again because I was very drunk okay but
I give you for asking that question
if you could switch drag with any of our
season 11 test who would it be
I was swapped with Akira Chanel
Davenport because a carrier is body ID
and in my mind I already said it I'm a
size 2 so I think I can fit her garments
and just be so cinched and pretty and
elegant and fish because a carrier you
can clock her but she's not a drag queen
that's a woman and as you can see I'm
the mother what would you take away from
soup to make yourself more fabulous the
split because this old lady can I do
that and this girl can do the split so
if I could steal that from Robert
snatchin RV if you could be any candy
what kind of candy would you be and why
it's our past children first it's our
danger tweet I'm going to wear but I
pass child I don't even like sour candy
but I would be a sour past children
[Music]